BNP Paribas Crédit Agricole Société
Générale points communs de ces trois
banques elle soutiennent des projets du
groupe Total énergie d'extraction de
pétrole selon les écologistes
d'extinction rébellion les militants
voient rouge très tôt ce matin ils ont
collé des affiches et asperger de
peinture et de liquide visqueux 4
agences bancaires de Tours une action
simultanée dans 10 villes de France
Clemenceau
affiche placardée à la colle végétale
peinture à l'eau jetée sur les vitrines
une action entreprise par les militants
d'extinction rébellion 37 sur plusieurs
banques du centre-ville cette nuit les
volontaires agissent masquées pour
protéger leur identité c'est pas
forcément pour pour ne pas être visible
du public mais c'est pour éviter de se
faire emmener en garde à vue là
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir mener à bien
l'action et si les si la police nous
voyait trop rapidement pourrait pas
amener au bout de fin à terme l'action
objectif ça lire l'image des banques
crédit agricoles BNP et Société Générale
des financeurs de projets selon
extinction rébellion
l'opération nommée banctro crade a été
coordonnée aujourd'hui dans plusieurs
villes de France afin d'interpeller
client et passants je peux comprendre
qu'en tout cas ça soit perçu un peu
comme violente en tout cas le but c'est
d'être
un peu dérangeant de déranger l'espace
public là ont du consentement des
banques privées mais surtout on a choisi
des disciples qui sont
vraiment dans le centre-ville dans le
centre passant de Tours pour être
visible pour que les passants passent
devant et s'interrogent seuls les
passants les plus matinaux on peut
apercevoir les affiches des 9h30 agents
Jaurès des gé à haute pression effacer
les traces de peinture et de colle une
plainte a été déposée par le Crédit
Agricole contacté les autres banques
concernées ne nous ont pas répondu à
temps